- [Ray] Principles for Success:
An Ultra Mini-Series Adventure
in 30 minutes and in eight episodes.
Episode Five: Everything is a Machine.
Sometimes things happen
that are hard to understand.
Life often feels so
difficult and complicated.
It's too much to take in all at once.
My deep pain led me to reflect
deeply on my circumstances.
It also led me to reflect on nature,
because it provides a
guide for what's true.
So I thought a lot about how
things work, which helped
to put me and my own
circumstances in perspective.
I saw that at the Big Bang,
all the laws and forces
of the universe were created
and propelled forward,
interacting with each other
as a perpetual motion machine
in which all the bits and
pieces coalesce into machines
that work for awhile, fall apart,
and then coalesce into new machines.
This goes on into eternity.
I saw that everything is a machine.
The structure and evolution of galaxies,
the formation of our own solar system,
the makeup of Earth's
geography and ecosystems,
our economies and markets, and each of us,
we individually are machines
made up of different machines,
our circulatory system, our nervous system
that produce our thoughts,
our dreams, our emotions,
and all the other aspects
of our distinct characters.
All of these different machines
evolve together through time
to produce the realities
we encounter every day.
And I realized that I
was just one tiny bit
in one nanosecond
deciding what I should do.
While that perspective might
sound very philosophical,
I found that it was very practical
because it showed me how I could deal
with my own realities in a better way.
For example, I observed
that most everything happens
over and over again in
slightly different ways,
some in obvious short term
cycles that are easy to recognize
so we know how to deal with
them, like the 24 hour day,
some so infrequently that
they haven't occurred
in our lifetimes, and
we're shocked when they do,
like the once in a hundred year storm,
and some we know exist
but are encountering
for the first time, like the
birth of our first child.
Most people mistakenly
treat these situations
as being unique and deal
with them without having
proper perspective or principles
to help them get through them.
I found that if instead of
dealing with these events
as one offs, I could see each
as just another one of those
and approach them in the same way
a biologist might approach an animal,
first identifying its species,
then drawing on principles
for dealing with it appropriately.
Because I could see
these events transpire in
pretty much the same ways over and over,
I could more clearly see the
cause-effect relationships
that govern their behaviors,
which allowed me to develop
better principles that I could express
in both words and algorithms.
I learned that while most
everyone expects the future
to be a slightly modified
version of the present,
it is typically very different.
That's because people are
biased by recent history
and overlook events that
haven't happened in a long time,
perhaps not even in their lifetime,
but they will happen again.
With that perspective, I
realize that what I missed
when I mistakenly called
for a Great Depression
was hidden in the patterns of history
and I could use my newfound
knowledge of these patterns
to make better decisions in the future.
And when I thought about my challenge
balancing risk and reward, I realized
that risk and reward
naturally go together.
I could see that to get
the most out of life,
one has to take more
risks and that knowing
how to appropriately
balance risk and reward
is essential to having
the best life possible.
Imagine you are faced with a choice
of having a safe boring life
if you stay where you are
or having a fabulous
one if you take the risk
of successfully crossing
a dangerous jungle.
That is essentially
the choice we all face.
For me, the choice was
clear, but that doesn't mean
the path forward was without challenges.
I still needed to face two big barriers
that we all must face.
In episode six, I'll share
some invaluable techniques
I learned about how to best do that.